-Our next guest is both the star
and executive producer
of "Grown-ish," which will air
its third season finale
this Thursday at 8:00 p.m.
on Freeform.
Let's take a look.
-I cannot believe I let you both
talk me into this.
I should not be here,
especially considering
that Rochelle asked me
to practically be besties
with her and Aaron
the other day.
-This is Aaron's big night
We are here to celebrate
the amazing thing he did
with the protest,
not to talk about
how you hijacked
the pinga from his girl.
-Exactly.
So take the shot,
put your big girl-panties on
and suck it up.
The night will be over
before you know it.
-Right.
'Cause it's a friend's
graduation at Titanium.
It's in and out.
How awkward can it be, right
Mm.
-Zoey! -Hey.
-Oh, my God!
-Hi.
-Hey, Rochelle!
-Please welcome to the sho
Yara Shahidi.
How are you, Yara?
-I'm good.
How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
And I think happy birthday
are in order.
I know it was last month,
but you turned 21.
-Yes.
-And, of course,
now it's not that unique.
We've all had a quarantine
birthday as we've gone
a full year here.
But how was yours?
-Mine was great.
I was saying I'm pretty luck
to have a family
that I love and like,
and all of our birthdays
are very close together.
So, mine's the 10th of February.
My brother is the 14th
of February, and then,
we just had a March 7th.
So it's like
a season of celebration.
-And you have been spending most
of this year with your family.
So it sounds like it's going
better than maybe it would
for people who don't like thei
family as much as you do.
-Yeah!
I'm pretty grateful.
I'm sure my brothers are tired
of seeing me around so much.
I went into my brother's roo
maybe yesterday
and just started making
random noise, and he's like,
"What is happening?"
This is the point in which w
are all starting to fall apart
-I also heard that when
you were growing up,
your parents would not
allow you guys
to watch TV during the week.
I'm assuming those rules
have been loosened
now that you are actually on TV?
-Yeah.
I mean,
that sounds so Draconian,
but it was just one of those
like, we were the kids
listening to audiobooks
and stuff,
and it wasn't until I became
a series regular on a show
that TV started happening
on Wednesdays.
-[ Laughs ] That's very --
They gave you one day back
So, I want to ask this.
You know, you play
a college student on the show,
and you are a college studen
in real life.
Sometimes we find out
that people who play
high school students
or college students on TV
are actually decades older
But this is a case
where this actually parallel
with your life.
How different
a college student are you
from the one you play on TV?
-Oh, polar opposites.
I mean, I've been playing Zoey
for seven years,
and it's been interesting
because I don't think
there's ever been one poin
in which we've converged
as human beings.
But this season, I feel like
life paralleled art, et cetera
in that, I mean, this season
Zoey's going
between work and school,
and it was literally
what I was doing,
just kind of
flying back and forth.
And before this,
it was so funny.
I had a meeting with a professor
who I really love.
And he was like,
"How much time do you have?"
I was like, "Funny you ask
I'm on the 'Seth Meyers' show in
like a couple minutes."
So, I only have like
a 20-minute window.
-I do hope that if
your professor is now checking
to make sure you were lying,
or I should say,
to make sure
you're telling you the truth
we should say hello to him
and thank you for watching
-Absolutely.
Thank you so much, Professor
-So you actually filmed al
of this before the pandemic.
This whole season was 2019
But now you're in preproductio
for season four,
which I imagine will make
being a college student
a little bit harder.
But, usually, how do you manag
the multitasking?
-So, season three, I was solidly
flying back and forth
twice a week,
which was interesting.
Got so many miles,
and so, that'll, I'm sure,
come back around and be
so helpful later in my life,
all the miles I got.
And then this one, I mean,
everything's on Zoom now.
So I'm reporting live
from my trailer
and will go into work
I think a couple --
in like a couple minutes
after this.
And it's actually strangely,
like, worked out.
But I've been to a total of like
12 different school programs
I was very much like
the educational guinea pig
not in a Frankenstein
type of way, with my family,
just trying to figure out
what education works.
So I've done
distance learning before.
And so this is kind of old hat
in a way that I'm grateful for
-You have your own
production company.
Your partner in your productio
company is your mother.
How has your working
relationship been so far?
-Yeah.
Okay, people that know me
and my mother, we've been
business partners for a minute
and, I mean, other than the fact
that we have different names
we're pretty much
the same human.
[ Both laugh ]
And so it really,
I think, if anything,
works out very well.
It's to the point
where people do double takes
They can't even identify which
one of us is on the phone.
All sorts of things.
But anyway, like,
we've been partners forever.
And then moving into productio
has been so beautiful
because we have
the same instincts.
And I think, you know,
being in a family comedy,
people don't necessarily
expect having darker shows
or more irreverent shows
coming out of our kind of
ecosystem
and our production company
But to have both of us
advocating for the same things
is pretty wonderful,
and we have too much
of a good time because we ca
really hype each other up
on our jokes and such.
So even if no one else gets it
I mean, there's always somebod
in the room
that's right there with you.
-So does that mean
that you never
have disagreements on projects
You're sort of in lockstep
on taste all the time?
-I mean, really,
it sounds like a mythical,
magical mother-daughter
relationship
that people don't see often.
And people are always trying
to pull out something craz
from us.
It just --
We're too similar.
[ Both laugh ]
-Yeah, I think it's
even more impressive
when you think,
"Man, I've never
seen mothers and daughters
get along that well,"
and certainly, I wouldn't thin
show business is where
that would be different.
So it's quite an accomplishmen
to both of you.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-I've also heard that
you are a comic-book fan.
Is this a true fact?
-Absolutely.
I have storylines as to wh
I belong in the
Marvel Comic Universe
that I made up.
-Well, that's good.
Well, hopefully,
someone at Marvel is watching.
It seems to me that you would be
a perfect fit
for the Marvel Universe.
-Oh, I had so many --
I was in 12 seconds of a movie
as Samuel L. Jackson's kid
at the age of like 13,
and I was like,
"If this is not an in,
then I don't know what is.
-[ Laughs ]
-Like, I need to be --
I gender swapped.
I was like,
"I should the be Nicole Fury,"
'cause Nick Fury has a son
I wrote a page for it,
a one-sheet.
Marvel Studios has a headquarter
right where we shoot
"Black-ish" and "Grown-ish."
I was like, "This is perfect
You can greenscreen me in.
-It sounds like they might hav
to put a photocopy of your fac
on the front door at Marve
to, maybe say, "Watch out.
We shouldn't
let this person in."
-Oh, I mean, if I'm not on a
watch list already, then maybe
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Congrats on season three
and as well on being
in production on season four
Really appreciate it.
-Thank you.